i want to ask you more about vanquish
this what's like the whole film what's
the film the premise for everything
i play victoria she's a single mom who
would do anything for her daughter which
is funny because i
i know another single mom that did
everything for a daughter growing up oh
my gosh that's so beautiful i'm taking a
minute katya
and it was oh my god i hope my kids are
so nice to me when i'm older
okay yeah because they're not kids
sometimes they're mean now were you mean
when you were little
uh yeah i mean we had out of time okay
good then this is promising okay cool
okay
i love my mum more than anything in the
world and we have been through a lot
that role in vanquish was important to
me because i understood
what it was like to be a single mom that
would do anything to your daughter and
so the story
was enough for me to want to do the film
that was sort of back in action
but i had started every day going i'm
not going to be the actor that i want if
i keep being what people want me to be
yeah who am i really and i'm like i'm
yes i'm strong
but i'm also funny and i'm caring and
i'm gentle and i love people with my
whole heart like and you want to play
all those roles i want to play all those
roles and i want to
you know be able to put things out there
that people in this time need
and they don't necessarily need
distractions and entertainment we love
popcorn we love action films and
popcorn with eminem's you know
but we also want heart and we want to
have like good uplifting stories and so
morgan plays he's my boss he's my
caretaker and
he puts me in a very compromising
position for
throughout the film by taking my child
and so i have to go and
sort of go back to a past that i was
hoping to forget in order to
he has you do things in order to keep
your daughter safe you do them
yeah wow i love it yeah i like can't
wait to see and then also i
i really i mean all the producers and
writers out there i personally want to
see her in a rom-com
because i don't know if you're into
rom-coms but i think
it would be awesome and i think you're
very funny and i think you're very
um i don't know i think funny people
like witty people are also very
intelligent and i love seeing strong
powerful vulnerable women and
roles like that so i would i would love
we should do one and we don't do enough
i
hate acting i'm not a good actor i'm
just not at all um
but i'd love to see you do it but um you
ruby and katya thank you so much
for joining us all the way from
australia mama
i hope it wasn't too stressful i was so
nervous that she'd be stressed you're
welcome anytime
katya we love you um well everybody
vanquishes in select theaters and on
apple tv april 16th
and on all video on demand april 20th
and on blu-ray and dvd on april 27th
yup i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever